so yesterday we started the show talking
about the retirement of Supreme Court
Justice Anthony Kennedy I told you in
absolutely no uncertain terms the total
unmitigated unfettered disaster that it
is Kennedy sort of the moderate vote in
the Supreme Court but somebody who did
support abortion rights somebody who did
support same-sex marriage rights and
many other important areas where he did
side with the more liberal progressive
justices he is going to be gone and he
is going to be replaced by some one of
Donald Trump's choosing who is going to
be without a doubt an extraordinarily
right-wing wacky ideologue maybe of
religious rightist or maybe a less
religious ideologue my bet would be on a
religious right ideologue and I
mentioned yesterday when we talked about
this that roe v wade is on the table
okay roe v wade could disappear as we
know it opening the door to states
banning abortion outright okay
what stands in the way of states saying
abortion is just illegal it's just it's
just illegal it's illegal that you can't
do abortions period is roe v wade and we
now have as i mentioned yesterday more
and more legal experts saying expect
state bans on abortion as a result of
this here is legal expert jeffrey toobin
supreme court expert jeffrey toobin
agreeing that abortion is in trouble he
appeared on CNN and he predicts that
within a year and a half we will have
twenty state-level abortion bans I think
sometimes we talk about Supreme Court it
too much in abstractions about dignity
and who's qualified and who's not
allowed
let's talk facts let's talk about what
America is going to be like that's
different you are going to see 20 states
passed laws banning abortion outright
just banning abortion and because they
know that there are now going to be five
votes on the Supreme Court to overturn
roe v wade and abortion will be illegal
in a significant part of the United
States in in 18 months
there is just no
doubt about that and that's why these
seats matters this is what's at stake
it's not just me saying it 20 states
according to Jeffrey Toobin are going to
go backwards to the back-alley abortions
to the home made abortions to the forced
miscarriage this is the direction and I
was thinking kind of scrambling really
to try to think of any way that this
entire fiasco might be an opportunity
and it's pretty grim but here it is okay
if we want to really work hard to find
something that could be called not even
a silver lining but an opportunity could
this fiasco be an opportunity to come to
the full realization that the United
States should be divided into more than
one country that the divisions are so
deep that grouping states into more than
one country might actually make sense
it's not gonna happen it's certainly not
peacefully anyway but that's how extreme
this has become and I recently read a
Handmaid's Tale by Margaret Atwood and
it was supposed to be a dystopian
fantasy not a prediction of 2020 for
America or whatever year it is that that
this is the direction things are going
to go but it's unfortunately becoming
closer and closer and closer to the
reality we're going to have to contend
with do you think the east and west
coasts could unite as one country with
the other country in the middle of not
contiguous SecureAuth that important is
not contiguous and that's scary to me I
don't know how you would do it I don't
know how you do it and really I've seen
actually interesting maps that divide
the u.s. into anywhere from 4 to 11
different countries which still would be
reasonably sized European countries
quite frankly that so I don't think it's
a population issue I know it's not going
to happen but I'm trying to say
something to the people who say there's
simply nothing we can do right remember
that Republicans were able to make life
hell for Obama during his first two
years before the Democrats had that
terrible 2010 midterm anything that
Donald Trump wants to do make it so
toxic
so untenable that you paralyze
government that's what needs to happen
pull out all the stops make the energy
required to do anything so completely
overwhelming and exhausting Supreme
Court nominee as an example you're not
going to stop
Trump from appointing someone unless you
can delay the appointment until maybe
Democrats take over the Senate and then
convince Democrats to just filibuster
the entire thing but even if you can't
stop it
make it difficult make it an uphill
battle so that by the time they get done
what it is they're trying to get done
it's a Pyrrhic victory one that is more
deflating than whatever benefit is
confirmed by actually conferred by
actually accomplishing what they wanted
to accomplish you aren't going to beat
them with logic and reason you need to
make legislating exhausting it should be
exhausting and unbearable to them to
have to go and do anything because of
how the left gets in the way I think
that's the only way Pat I can't think of
anything else that we can do it other
than of course voting at every
opportunity when it comes to this
abortion issue I think conservatives
would say that if you live in a state
that doesn't allow abortion anymore
after you know Roe vs. Wade is perhaps
overturned sure you can still use your
foot vote just move to a state that does
allow abortion yeah don't worry the
counter-argument yeah of course a lot of
people can't afford to do that a lot of
people also have family where they are
and the idea that hey just go somewhere
else
it lacks empathy which is sort of a
theme or on the right 15 16 17 years old
you can't necessarily just leave your
state and no doubt about it and
Republicans know how to get in the way
right Republicans know they did it to
Obama for most of his presidency
I believe that Democrats have a moral
duty at this point to do the exact same
thing if they have the spine for it and
if they have the tolerance for it I
genuinely don't know though whether
Democrats are actually up for doing this
I don't know that they are we've not
seen evidence so far that we can
actually count on Democrats to make any
accomplishment painstakingly exhausting
for Republicans if I had to bet and I
don't bet but if I bet I would probably
bet that the Democrats aren't willing to
do what it takes yeah I mean there are
some Democrats out there who are more
rough-and-tumble right the Bernie
Sanders types the Maxine Waters types
problem is you take a look at the
leadership it's folks like Nancy Pelosi
and Chuck Schumer and they're still you
know committed to being civil through
all of this
civility unfortunately at this point
imagine the people who make fun of the
left for policing tone are now calling
for civility do you see the glaring
hypocrisy and hilarious double standard
send me your thoughts about this
what should the left do what can the
left do beyond just calling your elected
officials and saying I hope that you'll
do this or that what should the left be
doing let me know I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show I'm really thrilled to
tell you that today's program is made
possible in part by better help.com
slash Pakman as many of you know I have
been working very hard on this program
to reduce stigma around mental health to
reduce stigma around seeking help and I
have a family that is very involved in
mental health and if you've not already
heard about better help it is a
tremendous resource better help gives
you through your phone and computer
affordable private access to licensed
trained accredited experienced
psychologists counselors therapists and
clinical social workers who were
dedicated to helping you through
whatever is going on in your life you
just go to better help calm slash Pakman
fill out a questionnaire they will match
you with a counselor that will work best
for you they are LGBT friendly you can
even say I want a counselor who's not
religious if that's important to you if
your initial match isn't a good vibe you
can switch to a different counselor and
the beauty is that not only do you get
unlimited counseling over videophone and
text from at home and on the go it is
way cheaper than in-person counseling
and after three months it becomes even
cheaper for you they also have financial
aid for people who need help paying but
you get the same professional licensed
therapy that you would by going to
someone's office and I believe that so
many people would benefit from therapy
whether you're dealing with an
cute situation in your life whether
there are bigger picture difficulties
that you're experiencing please consider
checking out better help calm slash
Pakman it's easy to sign up and get
started we've put a link in the
description if you're watching on
YouTube once again that is better help
calm slash PA que ma N